disent les écologistes c'est pas assez
disent les éleveurs et bien est-ce que
vous avez un point de vue là dessus
renaud girard
mais moi je trouve pourquoi ce que les
écologie ne se penche pas sur les brebis
pourquoi est ce qu'ils préfèrent les ou
aux brebis
moi j'aime bien la fontaine alors je
suis un peu du côté de l'agneau de la
brebis et le pastoralisme d'une veste au
réalisme voilà donc sur sa très étonnant
d'avoir cette espèce de la d'affection
pour pour le lou parce qu'en fait le
loup aime bien égorger les brebis mais
pour le plaisir parce qu'ils les mangent
pas tout ne se passe et 10000 parce que
sinon ils vraiment ce serait des groupes
voilà donc ccc et donc je comprends très
bien
ces bergers si vous voulez qu'ils
protègent leurs brebis et qui ne veulent
pas que iliad et nous comme ça voilà
alors est ce que on peut en garder
quelques wii quelques quelques spécimens
pourquoi pas mais je me demande si les
écologistes demain où certains
écologistes je suis pour l'air pur dans
les villes qu'on soit bien clair pour
moi c'est ça l'écologie est important
c'est plus de parts plus de diesel plus
de particules fines c'est ça qui est
important pour ça que je suis pour le
nucléaire parce que je suis écologique
maintenant mais c'est pour le nucléaire
parce que j'aime bien les purs entre
deux ans au look jamais vous êtes contre
les jambons qui nous vient d'allemagne
les particules fines qui nous viennent
hamad mais j'ai peur qu'ensuite on va on
va vouloir protéger des vipères par
exemple parce que là des pères est en
danger et c'est donc
donc je trouve effectivement qu un
abattage des noirs je ne sais pas là
c'est encore une question technique
combien l'ambiance plus supporter de
loups cissé 200-250 c'est en tout cas je
pense que la population des loups ne
doit pas croître dans nos campagnes
certainement pas non plus six mais allez
vous défendre le grand méchant loup
écoutez je trouve que c'est une
discussion qui est d'abord culturel
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
j'irai jusqu'au xxème siècle où était
vraiment l'espèce musique par définition
il y aurait jamais eu une discussion sur
faut-il l'abattre ou pas selon la
battait donc je trouve que renaud girard
est un peu un homme du 19e siècle
et court pour le calcul nous discuterons
de sa ensuite mais je pense que ce qui
est important c'est qu'à partir d'un
certain moment au fond au milieu du
xxème siècle on est passé d'une espèce
totalement nuisible à l'idée que c'était
une espèce en voie d'extinction et donc
en fait cette espèce de changement de
statut rend les choses compliquées
surtout quand par ailleurs on veut
préserver effectivement la possibilité
d'élever d'élever les brebis qui est
quelque chose qui préserve également la
biodiversité donc on est dans une espèce
de de conflit d'intérêts et puis ce qui
est très important aussi c'est que vous
avez l'impression qu'il faut tout de
suite choisir se choisir son camp c'est
à dire que si vous dites qu'il faut
qu'il faut garder des loups vous êtes
contre les brebis et vous êtes contre
les éleveurs et si vous dites que vous
trouvez qu'il faut garder des troupeaux
vous êtes contre les écologistes
donc moi je trouve que ce qui est
important là dedans c'est au fond de
proportions gardées et le plan loup de
nicolas hulot est intéressant parce
qu'ils fixent en fait une espèce de
quota
sur l'idée qu'on peut aller jusqu'à 10%
le fais jamais de 10 % ont des papiers
parce que dieu sait pas gros donc sur le
décret mais ce que je trouve très
intéressant dans la période actuelle
c'est qu'enfin on s'engage sur un débat
alors que ce que je voulais dire c'est
que quand on s'intéresse à la question
du loup on découvre que c'est un sujet
sur lequel il ya énormément de paranoïa
de secret on sait même pas exactement le
nombre de loups qu'il ya en france on ne
le dit pas publiquement de peur que les
éleveurs se dresse contre vous donc
c'est un sujet presque romanesque et sur
lequel on est à la fois donc dans le
culturel dans l'économique et dans
l'idée qu'une profession ne doit pas
être persécutés on aime le loup d'autant
plus qu'on est un habitant des villes et
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut que le
gouvernement essaie de faire en sorte
d'arbitré positivement pour les éleveurs
je reprend la parole chez renault car
nous accueillons valentin pilotes du
plateau
âge indifférent mais je suis je
m'accroche à mon siège valentin haüy
brin d'espoir est trop trop rapide vous
avez interrogé vous êtes allés plutôt
vous êtes penché sur les réseaux sociaux
et en fait on aime bien les loups sur
internet
oui on aime beaucoup les loups j'ai posé
la question sur twitter nos internautes
faut-il laisser vivre les loups la
réponse à l'éclair voilà ce qu'on m'a
répondu tout à l'heure la question ne
devrait même pas se poser
oui nous divisent laine ou bien sûr nos
dikaba bon voilà au delà de ces réponses
c'est simple on a aux euros sur twitter
toujours qui nous signale que en
régulant chaque année le nombre ça
pourrait être intéressant de voir ce
qu'on peut faire
en fait c'est déjà le cas donc à 10% par
an elle signalé avec cet arrêté mi
interministériel ministérielle de
juillet mais nos internautes en fait un
exemple qui revient en boucle c'est le
cas de l'italie alors pourquoi l'italie
je vais vous expliquer en italie les
bergers ont le même phénomène nous 17
internautes du figaro.fr on va le voir
dans un instant alors comment font-ils
c'est très simple il ferme
leurs moutons dans des enclos et les
fonds surveillés par des chiens qui
peuvent garder un oeil en l'occurrence
sur sur ces dernières on a encore paul
sur lefigaro.fr qui nous dit que c'est
quand même bizarre que du côté italien
le sujet du loup soit si peu évoquée
alors que pourtant les loups la base
sont bien plus nombreux on peut pas
vérifier les chiffres mais apparemment
c'est le cas et c'est le cas ils le sont
bien plus si damas constate que la
cohabitation se passe très bien en
italie à des lieues de kiss de ce qui
pourrait se passer en france en france
d'une part beaucoup de bergers sont
devenus fainéants et cet internaute
c'est assez marrant il parle de son
voisin en l'occurrence qui hébergeait et
qui nous signale que il surveille mal
ses troupeaux qu'il deviendrait
apparemment fainéants et qu'ils ne
lèveraient plus des chiens en
l'occurrence qui pourrait monter la
garde contre les loups
chez lui le mot de la fin un argument
recevable résolument le mot de la fin
il ira à cet internaute qui nous signale
que les bergers devront s'adapter à
l'espace sauvage qui n'est pas un espace
destiné naturellement à l'élevage
merci adélaïde zulfikarpasic ya déjà eu
des sondages concernant ce que les
français pensent non ça ne me dit rien
en revanche ce qui est intéressant sur
la position des internautes notamment
des gens qui sont sur les réseaux
sociaux ça relance que disait le succès
parce que en général les gens qui
expriment sur les réseaux sociaux et
notamment sur twitter ce sont plutôt des
gens qui ont un profil jeunes urbains
citadins voilà ce n'est pas très
surprenant
après il n'y a pas eu de sondages mais
je pense qu'on retrouverait
effectivement cette espèce de
d'antagonisme entre ce que les français
ils sont à la fois attachée à l'écologie
et en même temps ils ont une bonne image
des éleveurs a donc peut-être qu'on
pourrait ne pas les opposer élevage et
loup mais honnêtement dont je connais
pas la réponse à la question un joli
commentaire d'aurélien sur twitter qui
nous dit pas ce que je colle il ya des
loups à quatre pattes et d'autres à 2
dès qu'elle parle et vous est bien
plutôt de ceux à quatre pattes chers
aurélien alexis lacroix vous allez avoir
le mot de la fin
mais vous avez 15 secondes parce
qu'ensuite on rend l'antenne ça va être
dur alors sur sur les loups je pense
qu'il faut pas antagonisent et les
bergers j'aime les vergers moi je ne me
présente pas comme vous dans une
circonscription électorale des pyrénées
atlantiques et je vous pourrez et
j'aurais leurs suffrages mais néanmoins
envoyé cette idée de tuer des loups même
pour moi elle est absurde et donc le
maximum à mon avis qu on peut admettre
et qu'on peut autoriser pour cette
liquidation
je crois que c'est le plan hulot mais si
on allait au delà si on cédait aux
demandes des bergers dont je comprends
par ailleurs les inquiétudes
on serait dans une folie car cette
réintroduction du loup et je rejoins
totalement ce qu'a dit lucide elle va
dans le sens de la restauration de cette
espèce de continuum qui a existé
longtemps entre les hommes et ces bêtes
là qui sont après tout des bêtes de
l'entourage là pour le coup on est très
loin des autres exemples que vous
preniez ça n'a rien à voir avec des
anguilles ou je ne sais quel
hyper ou je ne sais quel animal sordide
il ya eu une amitié il ya eu
historiquement une activité d'une amitié
de l'homme et dieu nous et s'est il tout
simplement cela que peut-être sur un
mode carnavalesque on a ressuscité mais
maintenant faut en tirer les
conséquences et avoir un esprit de
responsabilité
merci beaucoup pour ce magnifique
plaidoyer prolos merci à tous les quatre
à tous les cinq d'avoir été là et